تعاني بعض المطاعم الشهيره في السعوديه من
محاولات تقليد اسمائها وشعاراتها الى درجه
تقترب من حاله التطابق وان كانت المساله
واضحه في نشاط المطاعم الا انها في
حقيقتها تطالب درجات متفاوته بقيه الانشطه
التجاريه كل دوله تعاني كما تعاني من
الجريمه هذا جزء من انواع الجرائم وفيه
اجهزه مثل ما في هناك في اجهزه عندنا
تتولى مكافحه والرقابه ولكن دائما هذه
الاعمال الا ما يتم شخص او شخصين او ثلاثه
قد يتجاوزوها لكن كمشكله نقول هذه ظاهره
بالسوق السعودي
العطور والمستلزمات الرياضيه من ابرز
القطاعات التي تقلد العلامات التجاريه
فيها بسهوله عمليات التقليد لكن الخطوره
تكمن في تقليد منتجات اخرى مثل الادويه
وقطاعي غيار السيارات
ويمكن اكبر مشكله عندنا انه ما نزل بعض
الناس يتكلموا انه عادي يجيب لك قطعه
تجاريه متنازنه انه مثلا قطع تجاريه اللي
يشير لها غالبا تكون لها علاقه بقطاع
السيارات هي عباره عن فرامل مقلده قدود
بحياه اهله واولاده عشان يوفر 50 ريال
فهذه مشكله لكن القطاعات كلها متاثره لكن
القطاع الدوائي
من القطاعات اللي يصير فيها حاجه ثانيه
نوع ثاني من الغش اللي هو تقليد البراءات
اكثر من الف ومئه قضيه تتعلق بتقليد
العلامات التجاريه رصدتها هيئه الملكيه
الفكريه السعوديه خلال العام الماضي فيما
من المتوقع ان تنخفض تلك القضايا خلال
الفتره القادمه مع تشديد الرقابه الحكوميه
التي تزايدت مؤخرا من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه